What are your plans for the weekend, Changmin?
Nothing much, really. I might meet up with a few of my Korean friends and have some drinks.
How about you? What are you doing this weekend?
I might go to church.
Do you go to church every Sunday?
Yes, most of the time.
But I am going to visit my grandfather in two weeks, so I can't go to church then.
Don't you usually go to church on Sundays?
Actually, I am a Buddhist, so I don't really go to church services.
A Buddhist? Wow, I think you're the first buddhist I've ever met!
Well, there are a lot of Buddhists in Korea.
I'm not sure, but I think about half of the population are Buddhists.
I guess most Americans are Christians, right?
You're right.